>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
My name is Rob Casper.
I'm the head of the Poetry and
Literature Center and I'm thrilled
to welcome you to this afternoon's
event, celebrating the poetry
of Pablo Neruda and featuring
Forrest Gander and Marjorie Agosín.
First, let me ask you to
do what I'm going to do,
which is to turn those wonderful
electronic devices that you have
to make sure that they
don't interfere
with this afternoon's event.
Second, I'd like to note that
this program is being recorded
and by participating, you give us
for future use of the recording.
Tonight's event is cosponsored by
the library's Hispanic division
and the Poetry and
Literature Center.
Let me tell you a little
bit about the center.
We are home to the Poet
Laureate Consulting Poetry,
the first acting Hispanic poet
laureate, Juan Felipe Herrera,
who is a force of nature.
In addition to trying to
keep up with Juan Felipe,
we put on 30 to 40 programs
like this throughout the year.
To find out more about our
series and our literary programs
at the Library of Congress, you
can sign our signup sheet outside.
You can also visit our website, www.
Lsc.gov/poetry.
Talia Guzman Gonzalez
reference librarian
from the Hispanic division
will now introduce the event.
Please, join me in welcoming her.
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman: Hello
and welcome everyone
with this very special
day, February 14th.
I am a reference librarian in
the Hispanic division and I would
like to present our
two presenters today.
First, Marjorie Agosín
was born, I just learned,
very close to the Library of
Congress, right here in [inaudible],
Maryland, but left
very, very early to live
in Chile, where she was raised.
Her family moved to the United
States soon before the coo
that installed Augusto
Pinochet back to the states.
Agosín earned her bachelor's
from the University of Georgia
and a masters and a PhD
from Indiana University.
Both her scholarship
and her creative work,
she focuses on social justice,
feminism and remembrance.
In 1986, Agosín published
the book, "Pablo Neruda,"
as part of Twain's
world author's series,
a series of literary criticisms,
offering in depth introductions
to the lives and works of
writers, the history and influence
of literary movements
and the development
of literary of [inaudible].
Agosín is the author of
numerous works of poetry,
fiction and literary criticism.
Her collection include The Angle of
Memory, The Alphabet in my Hands,
a Ride in Life, Always
from somewhere else,
a Memoir of my Chilean Jewish
father, An absence of shadows,
Melodious Women and A
Crossroads and A Star Memoires
of a Jewish girl in
Chile, among others.
Agosín has received many honors
and awards for writing and work
as a human rights activists
including a Jeanette Rankin award
in human rights and a United Nations
Leadership award for human rights.
The Chilean government honored
her with a Gabriela Mistral Medal
for lifetime achievement.
Agosín is the Luella LeMer Slaner
professor in Latin American studies
and a professor of Spanish
at Wellesley College.
Forrest Gander was born in
California and grew up in Virginia
and attended the college
of William and Mary
where he majored in Geology.
After earning an MA in Literature
from San Francisco State University,
Gander moved to Mexico, then
to Arkansas, where his poetry,
informed by his knowledge of Geology
turned its attention to landscape
as foreground or source of action.
He is the author of 13 poetry
collections and two novels,
including "I against I, Torn Awake"
and "Science and Steeple Flower."
He is the editor of Mouth to Mouth,
Twelve Contemporary Mexican Women,
a Bilingual Anthology of
Contemporary Mexican Poets
and the translator of No Shelter,
the selected poems
of Pura Lopez Colome.
Gander's critically
acclaimed translations
of Pablo Neruda are included in The
Essential Neruda Selected Poems"
from 2004 and in 2016, he
published a bilingual edition
of Twenty Previously Unknown
and Unseen Neruda Poems,
which are presenting here today,
then come back, The Lost Neruda.
He won the Pen Translation
award for the book, The Night,
by Bolivian poet, Jaime Sáenz.
Gander has won the Reading Writers
Award, a Howard Foundation Award,
the Jessica Novel Maxwell Memorial
Prize, two Gertrude Stein Awards
for innovative North American
writing and fellowships
from the National Endowment for
the Arts, the Guggenheim Foundation
and the United States Artists.
He has taught at Harvard and
Brown University and also last
but not least, the man of the hour
who is making all this
possible, Pablo Neruda.
He's the author of more
than 50 books including
The Poetry Collection,
Veinte Poemas de Amor y una Cancion
desesperada, Twenty Love Poems
and a Song of Despair, Residencia
en la Tierra, Residence on Earth
and Alturas de Machupichu,
the Heights of Machupichu,
as well as his autobiography,
Confieso que he Vivido Memorias.
In 1971, Neruda was awarded
the noble prize for Literature.
His other honors include The
National Prize for literature
of Chile, the International Peace
Prize and the Stallion Peace Prize.
Alongside a prolific
literary career,
Neruda served as a Chilean diplomat
and sought a career in politics.
In 1945, he was elected senator
of the republic as a member
of the communist party, which
was outlawed four years later.
The poet sought exile in Mexico
and later toured Europe and Asia.
He returned to Santiago, Chile
in 1952 where he continued
to write until his death in 1973.
I want to take this opportunity
to invite you to also listen
to Pablo Neruda in the archive
of Hispanic Literature on tape,
curated by the Hispanic Division.
We have some flyers
outside for you to access,
learn to access the archives,
our marvelous collection
and because it is always wonderful
to have poets, in this case, poets,
right, reading to you,
please join me
in welcoming Forrest
Gander and Marjorie Agosín.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
One more thing before I forget,
we will have questions at the end
of the program and Forrest will
be reading some poems for us now.
Thank you.
>> Georgette Dorn: When
we start these readings,
one will we do the poem
in English and then
after we read it in Spanish.
>> Forrest Gander: So one person
who wasn't introduced
here is Georgette Dorn,
who has been like the anchor of the
Hispanic Literature Program here
at the Library of Congress
for a very long time.
[ Applause ]
I'm really glad to be
here with Marjorie,
who has also been a really
significant figure as both a poet
and a translator, and
an advocate for poetry
and her Latin American poetry
for as long as I've been writing.
So Happy Valentine's Day.
I love that you came out to listen
to Neruda on Valentine's Day.
So, yeah, we'll read
a couple of poems.
I think we need to start,
Marjorie, no, with a love poem?
So this is a poem --
let's see -- I'm not sure.
My numbers are going to
be different than yours.
Never Alone with You.
One of the things l like in
this poem a lot is the way
that the figure of the beloved mixes
with the figure of the landscape
and this is something for someone
as heterosexual as Pablo Neruda,
it's kind of interesting to think
that one way of reading his work is
that the two greatest influences on
him were a gay man and a gay women,
Walt Whitman and Gabriela
Mistral and it's Gabriela Mistral,
some of her more complex poetry that
mixes landscape and psychy in a way
that I think influences Neruda.
So these poems, as
Georgette asks me to tell you,
were just discovered
three years ago.
Matilda Rutia, Neruda's wife, had
been through all of his stuff,
but not as carefully
as Dariel Oasis,
the head of the Neruda
Foundation, in Chile,
who after Neruda widow's death
began to go through and document all
of the materials and began to
find things, written on the backs
of napkins, written on menus,
stuffed in other manuscripts
that no one had seen.
They were completely unseen
poems and when I heard about it,
I thought, "Oh, this is terrible,"
and when they published a book three
years ago in Spain, Latin America,
I thought, "Oh, they're just
squeezing stuff Neruda really didn't
want to have published and
making a dollar on it."
And then I saw the reviews and
the reviews were startling good
and then I had the opportunity
to translate the work and looked
at it, and it was Neruda.
It was the real thing.
So I was really pleased
to get to do it.
This one, listen to how the
erotism is mixed the landscape.
"Never alone, with
you over the earth,
crossing through fire, never alone.
With you in the forest, finding
again dawn's stiff arrow,
the tender moss of spring.
With you in my struggle, not the
one I chose, but the only one,
with you through the streets
and sand, with you, my love,
my exhaustion, the bread, the wine,
poverty and glint of one coin,
wounds, sorrow, happiness.
All the light, shadow,
stars, all the cut wheat,
the corellas of giant sun flowers,
defeated by their very fullness,
the cormorant's flight nailed to
the sky like a coastline cross,
all the space, the autumn, the
carnations, never alone, with you.
Never alone, with you, earth.
With, the sea, my life, all I am,
all I give and everything I sign,
the substance of this love, the
earth, the sea, bread, a life."
[ Applause ]
>> Marjorie Agosín:
Thank you very much.
I'm also very honored and happy
to be here with all of you,
with the Library of Congress,
with Georgette and Forrest
that I've never met personally,
but I feel I do know them,
so it's a wonderful opportunity
and also to celebrate love, hope,
sensuality and the world would be
a much better for everyone even
if presidents read
poetry more often.
So I'll read in Spanish
Neruda's poem
and you will remember the
beautiful translation of Forrest.
"Nunca solo, contigo por la
tierra, atravesando al fuego.
Nunca solo, contigo por los bosques
recogiendo la flecha entumecida de
la aurora, el tierno
musgo de la primavera.
Contigo en mi batalla, no la
que yo escogí, sino la única.
Contigo por las calles y la arena,
contigo, el amor, el cansancio,
el pan, el vino, la pobreza
y el sol de una moneda,
las heridas, la pena, la alegría.
Todo la luz, la sombra, las
estrellas, todo el trigo cortado,
la corolas del girasol gigante,
doblegadas por su proprio caudal,
el vuelo del cormorán, clavado
al cielo come cruz marina,
todo el espacio, el otoño, los
claveles, nunca solo, contigo.
Nunca solo, contigo, tierra.
Contigo el mar, la vida, cuanto soy,
cuanto doy y cuanto
canto esta materia --
amor, la tierra, el
mar, el pan, la vida."
[ Applause ]
>> Marjorie wanted to read this one,
which I haven't read
before out loud.
Do you want to read
it in Spanish first?
Do you want to hear it in
Spanish first or English first?
[ Inaudible ]
You have a choice?
What did you say?
>> En español al principio.
>> Forrest Gander: Okay.
>> Marjorie Agosín:
Okay, poema cuatro.
"¿Que entrega a tu mano de oro la
hoja de otoño que canta o vas tú
repartiendo ceniza en
los ojos del cielo,
o a ti te rindió la manzana su luz
olorosa o tu decidiste el color del
océano en complicidad con la ola?
Ha sido la ley de la lluvia
cambiar la sustancia del llanto,
caer y elevar, educar el amargo
silencio con lanzas que el viento y
el tiempo transforman
en hojas y aromas.
Y si sabe que el dia entusiasta
corriendo en su carro de trigo es un
movimiento florido de un siclo de
sombra en el mundo y yo me pregunto
si tu no trabajas tejiendo el estaño
secreto del blanco navío que cruza
la noche nocturna o si de tu sangre
minúscula no nace el color del
durazno, si no son tus manos
profundas las que hacen que fluyan
los ríos, si no hacen tus ojos
abiertos en medio del cielo en
verano que caiga del sol a la tierra
su espada amarilla entonces recorre
su rayo cruzando tu copa incitante
arenas, corolas, volcanes, jazmines,
desiertos, raíces, y lleva tu
esencia a los huevos del bosque a la
rosa furiosa de los abejorros,
avispas, leones, serpientes,
halcones, y muerden y pican y clava
y rompen tus ojos llorando pues fue
tu semilla en la tierra, tu ovario
impetuoso el que repartió por la
tierra la lengua del sol iracundo.
Reposa tu pura cadera y el
arco de flechas mojadas,
extiende en la noche los
pétalos que forman tu forma,
que suban tus piernas de arcilla el
silencia y su clara escalera peldaño
a peldaño volando conmigo en el
sueño yo siento que asciendes
entonces el árbol sombrío
que canta en la sombra.
Oscura es la noche del
mundo sin ti, amada via,
y apenas diviso el origen,
apenas comprendo el idioma,
con dificultades descifro
las hojas de los eucaliptus.
Por eso si extiendes tu cuerpo y de
pronto en la sombra sombría asciende
tu sangre en el rio del tiempo y
escucho que pasa a través de mi amor
las cascada del cielo y que tu
formas parte del fuego que corre
escribiendo mi genealogía me
otorgue tu vida adorada la rama que
necesitaba, la flor que dirige
las vidas y las continua,
el trigo que muere en el
pan y reparte la vida,
el barro que tiene los
dedos mas suave del mundo,
los trenes que silban a través
de las ciudades salvajes,
el monto el los alhelíes, el
peso del oro en la tierra,
la espuma que sigue al navío
naciendo y muriendo y el ala del ave
marina que vuela en la
ola como en un campanario.
Yo paso mi angosta mirada por el
territorio terrible de aquellos
volcanes que fueron el
fuego natal, la agonía,
las selvas que ardieron hasta las
pavesas con pumas y pájaros, y tú,
compañera tal vez eres
hija de la huma,
tal vez no sabia que viene del
parto del fuego y la furia.
La lava encendida formo con
relámpagos tu poco morado,
tu sexo en el musgo del roble
quemado como una sortija en un nido,
tus dedos alli entre las llama,
tu cuerpo compacto salió
de las ojos del fuego,
y en eso recuerdo que aun es
posible observar tu remoto linaje de
panadería, aun eres pan de la
selva, ceniza del trigo violento."
It goes on.
"Oh amor, de la muerte a la vida
una hoja del bosque, otra hoja,
se pudre el follaje
orgulloso en el suelo,
el palacio del aire y del trino,
la casa suntuosa vestida de
verde decae en la sombra,
en el agua, en el escalofrió.
Se sabe que alli germinaron en la
podredumbre mojada semillas sutiles
y vuelve la acacia a elevar
su perfume en el mundo.
Mi amor, mi escondida, mi
dura paloma, mi ramo de noche,
mi estrella de arena, la seguridad
de tu estirpe de rosa bravía acude a
la guerras de mi alma quemando en la
altura la clara fogata y marcho en
la selva rodeado por
los elefantes heridos,
resuena un clamor de tambores que
llaman mi voz en la lluvia y marcho,
acompaño mis pasos a mi desvarió
hasta ese momento en que surge tu
torre y su cupula y encuentro
extendiendo la mano tus ojos
silvestres que estaban
mirando mi sueño y la cepa de
aquellos quebrantos.
La ola delgada creció como crece
la luna delgada en su cielo creció
navegando en el aire sin prisa y sin
mancha y no supusimos que tu y yo
formábamos parte de su movimiento,
ni solo cabellos, idiomas, arteria,
orejas componen la sombra
del hombre sin como un hilo,
una hebra mas dura
que nada y que nadie,
el tiempo subiendo y gastando
y creciendo en la hora delgada.
Buscando los muros de Angol a la luz
del roció en la niebla supimos que
ya no existían, quedo devorado en la
guerra el bastión de madera maciza y
apenas surgía en la luz moribunda la
sombra o la huella o el polvo de un
hueso quemado.
Los boques del Sur soñoliento
cubrieron con enredaderas la guerra
y la paz de los muertos,
la ira y la sangre remota.
Sesenta y cuatro años arrastra este
siglo y sesenta en este año llevaban
los míos, ahora ¿De quién son los
ojos que miran los números muerto?
¿Quién eres amigo,
enemigo de mi paz errante?
Sabes cómo fueron los dias,
la crónica, las revoluciones,
los viajes, las guerras, las
enfermedades, las inundaciones,
el tiempo que a veces
pareció un soldado vencido,
como se gastaron zapatos corriendo
por las oficinas de otoño ¿Que
hacían los hombres
dentro de una mina,
en la altura plateada de
Chuquicamata o en el mar antártico
de Chile infinito dentro de
un navío cubierto de nieve?
No importa, mis paso antiguos
te irán enseñando y cantando,
lo amargo y eléctrico de este tiempo
impuro y radioso que tuvo colmillos
de hiena, camisa atómicas
y alas de relámpago,
para ti que tienes los ojos que aun
no han nacido abriré la paginas de
hierro y roció de un siglo maldito
y bendito, de un siglo moreno,
con color de hombres oscuros y boca
oprimida que cuando viví comenzaron
a tener conciencia y alcantarillado,
a tener banderas que fueron tiñendo
los siglos a fuerza de sangre
y suplicio.
The end.
[ Applause ]
>> Forrest Gander: So I'm not
going to read that whole thing
because it would take up -- it's
the longest poem in the book.
It would take up the most time.
I think I'll the very end of it
and then we'll read
one more shorter poem
and then maybe we can
have a discussion.
I'm really interested in
the things you have to say
and what Georgette
Dorn has to say also.
Does that seem okay?
Okay. So this is the end
of that beautiful poem.
So it doesn't have a name.
>> Georgette Dorn: I know.
It's the fourth one.
>> Forrest Gander: Oh, it's
number four, numero cuatro.
"Sixty-four years this
century drags along and sixty
of them this year are mine,
now whose eyes stare
into the dead numbers?
Who are you, fiend,
enemy of my errant peace?
You know how the days went,
the chronicle, the revolutions,
the trips, the wars, the
sicknesses, the deluges,
the time that could seem like a
routed soldier, how shoes wore
out racing through the offices of
autumn, what the men were doing
in a mine, on the silvery
heights of Chuquicamata
or on infinite Chile's Antarctic
sea inside a ship shrouded in snow.
No matter, my ancient ways will
keep teaching and singing to you
of what's bitter and electric in
t his impure, this radiant time
with its hyena fangs, atomic
shirts, and wings of lightning,
for you with eyes yet to be born
I'll open the iron and dew pages
to a blasted and blessed century, a
century gone brown as dark-colored
with tormented mouths who, in my
lifetime, came into a conscious
and decent plumbing and
came to claim a flag stained
by centuries of blood and torture."
The beautiful thing
about this edition,
the book that Cooper Canyon
did is that they included color
or holographic plates of Neruda's
handwriting and because a lot
of it is on manuscripts, a lot of it
you see and it's a beautiful thing
for us as poets because
you see Neruda thinking.
You see what he crosses out.
In that first poem that we
started with, for instance,
it starts out with a terrible line.
It starts out with a line, my
translation, "You are not made
of dreams beloved love,
and held to the light,
you're like an agrarian
grape," that's uva agria.
He crossed that out and started
again with that "Never alone
with you," which worked way better.
I think we'll just finish here with
one of the last poems in the book,
which Neruda writes during the space
arrays and he has gotten a chance
to meet a few of the cosmonauts
and he is fascinated, of course,
at the beginning of this
time, as everyone was then
with the notion what's beyond
the earth, of men going away
from the earth into galactic space
and he has an opportunity to ask one
of the cosmonauts, Herman Titov,
if he could see Chile from up there
and Titov said, "Well, you
know, I saw some mountains
down in the southern
part of the continent.
I'm sure that was Chile," and
Neruda was really satisfied
that Chile could be
seen from deep space.
Neruda also had the hots
for a cosmonaut named
Valentina Tereshkova.
So this really beautiful
poem about imaging that space
and the first people there.
"Those two solitary men,
those first men up there.
What of ours did they bring them?
What from us, the men of earth?
It occurs to me that the
light was fresh then,
that an unwinking star
journeyed along, cutting short
and linking distances, their faces
unused to the awesome desolation,
in pure space among astral bodies
polished and glistening like grass
at dawn, something new came from
the earth, wings or bone coldness,
enormous drops of water or surprised
thought, a strange bird throbbing
to the distant human heart and
not only that but cities, smoke,
the roar of crowds,
bells and violins,
the feet of children leaving school.
All of that is alive
in space from now
on because the astronauts
didn't go by themselves.
They brought our earth, the
odors of moss and forest,
love the crisscrossed limbs of
men and women, terrestrial rains
over the prairies, something floated
up like a wedding dress
behind the two spaceships.
It was our spring on earth
blooming for the first time
that conquered an inanimate heaven,
depositing in those altitudes
the seed of our kind.
[ Applause ]
>> Marjorie Agosín:
"Estos dos hombres solos,
estos primeros hombres allá arriba
¿que llevaron consigo de nosotros?
¿De nosotros los hombres
de la tierra?
Se me ocurre que aquella
luz fue nueva,
aquella estrella aguda que viajaba,
que tocaba y cortaba las distancias,
aquellos rostros nuevos
en la gran soledad,
en el espacio puro entre los astros
finos y mojados como la hierba en el
amanecer, algo nuevo venia de
la tierra, alas o escalofrió,
grande gotas de agua o
pensamiento imprevisto,
ave extraña que latía con
el distante corazón humano.
Pero no solo aquello, sino
ciudades, humo, ruido de multitudes,
campanas y violines, pie de
niños saliendo de la escuela,
todo eso en el espacio
vive ahora desde ahora,
porque los astronautas no
solos, llevaban nuestra tierra,
olor de musgo y bosque, amor,
enlace de hombres y mujeres,
lluvia terrestre sobre la Prader,
algo flotaba como un vestido de
novia detrás de las dos naves del
espacio: era la primavera de la
tierra que florecía por primera vez,
que conquistaba el cielo inanimado
dejando en las alturas la semilla
del hombre."
[ Applause ]
>> Forrest Gander:
Georgette Dorn has asked us
to read one more so
why don't we do that.
This is dated January 10th 1973,
so it's just before the poet
dies and he wrote "La Negra."
I've seen -- if you go visit
Neruda's houses, three of them,
lived well for a communist.
You'll see this old fashion phone
that we remember from like the 50s
and 60s that he's talking
about here.
So we'll throw this poem in.
I think it's 19, Marjorie to give
you a sense of his sense of humor
and the lost that it would have been
if this poem was never recovered.
It's found in a notebook on which
the first page, the poet writes,
" I began on the first
days of January 1973,
sick in bed with a bad hip, this
book titled, "Chosen Defects
and Others, Secret Poems."
And it stayed secret.
"From isolation, from the
hostile bonehead I've always been
since even before I was born,
between pride and the terror
of living without being loved,
I've come to shake hands
with all the world and,
without wanting to at first,
I've let myself take phone
calls, suffering a voice,
some advice through a wire,
a metallic transmission,
until finally I took leave
from myself and raising my arms
as though before a pointed gun,
I gave in to the degradations
of the telephone.
I who conducted myself with
such singular tact backing away
from sterile offices, from
offensive industrial palaces only
to see some black apparatus that
even with its silence, insults me.
Me, a poet clumsy as a duck on
land, degrading myself to the point
of yielding my superior ear, which
I consecrated innocently to birds
and music, to this everyday
prostitution of fixing my ear
to an enemy trying to
take control of my being.
I came to be a telefiend, a
telephony, a sacred telephant,
I prostrated myself
whenever the ringing
of that horrid despot demanded
my attention, my ears and blood,
when a voice mistakenly asked for
technical information or an escort,
or it was a relative I
detested, a forgotten aunt,
wholly objectionable, a National
Prize alcoholic who longed
to smack me or a blue-tinged, syrupy
actress who wanted to violate me,
seduce me with her pink telephone.
I've changed clothes,
roles, I'm all ears.
I live trembling that they
won't call me or that they will,
those idiots, my anxiety is
medication proof, doctors, priests,
politician, maybe I'm turning
myself into a telephone,
an abominable black-lacquered
instrument
through which others communicate
the contempt they'll devote to me
when I'm good for nothing but the
wasps that converse over my body."
[ Applause ]
>> Marjorie Agosín: Neruda
didn't live to see smart phones.
Okay. "Del incomunicado,
del ignorante hostil que yo fui
siempre desde antes de nacer,
entre el orgullo y el terror
de vivir sin ser amado,
pase a darle la mano a todo el mundo
y me deje telefonear sin ganas al
principio, aceptando una
voz, un alambrico consejo,
una metálica comunicación hasta
que ya me fui de mi yo mismo y
levantando como antes un revolver
los brazos me entregue a las
degradaciones del teléfono.
Yo que me fui con tacto singular,
alejando de claras oficinas,
de ofensivos palacios industriales,
solo de ver un aparato negro
que aun silencioso me insultaba,
yo poeta torpe como pato en tierra,
fui corrompiéndome hasta
conceder mi oreja superior,
que consagre con inocencia
a pájaros y música,
a una prostitución de cada dia,
enchufando el oído el enemigo
que se fue apoderando de mi ser.
Pase a ser telefin,
telefonino, telefante sagrado,
me prosternaba cuando la espantosa
campanilla del déspota pedía mi
atención, mis orejas y mi sangre,
cuando una voz equivocadamente
preguntaba por técnicos o putas,
o era un pariente que yo detestaba,
una tía olvidad, inaceptable,
un Premio Nacional alcoholista que
a toda costa quería pegarme o una
actriz tan azul y almibarada
que quería violarme,
seducirme empleando
un teléfono rosado.
He cambiado de ropa, de
costumbres, soy solamente orejas,
vivo temblando de que me llamen
o de que me llamen los idiotas.
Mi ansiedad resistió medicamentos,
doctores, sacerdotes, estadistas,
tal vez voy convirtiéndome
en teléfono,
en instrumento abominable y negro
por donde comuniquen los demás el
desprecio que me consagraran cuando
yo no sirva para nada es decir para
que hablen a través de
mi cuerpo las avispas."
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Georgette Dorn: And you
decided to write poetry.
Tell us about it.
>> Marjorie Agosín:
Where is my telephone?
This very afternoon, Georgette
said how did you become a poet,
I think really it is fate, it
is a form of destiny, of birth
and consider all the
other professions
that [inaudible] vocation,
this is an amazing one.
I used to spend summer in a
small [inaudible] village called,
"El Quisco," which is very close
to Isla Negra and my mother --
I always asked my mother to take
me to see the poet, el poeta.
So I was about eight years old and
I saw this enormous human being
who was in a poncho and I was
fascinated by his notebook
and a green pen, sitting
on the rock,
looking at the sea and writing.
I thought, as a young girl, that
that was an extraordinary to look
at the sea and write and
he inspired me to invite
or imagine and to be a poet.
It's not that difficult
to be a poet in Chile.
We have very good poets
and very bad poets,
but everyone is somehow thinking to
the Arts with beauty and even today,
the restaurants, this lady
from El Salvador knew much more
about Pablo Neruda than thousands
elementary and high school teachers
from the state of Wisconsin.
Do you Neruda?
Only two raised their hands,
so poetry is very much
a part of Latin America.
>> Georgette Dorn: Thank you.
When did you discover,
Forrester, Neruda,
in what part of your
wonderful career?
>> Forrest Gander: In
my wonderful career.
I didn't discover Neruda until I
was in college and then probably
like oh, right, right, microphone.
>> Teléfono.
>> Forrest Gander: Mi telefono.
I didn't read Neruda in high school.
I read in college and like a lot
of us, when I'd fallen in love,
you look for someone that
can articulate that better
than you're doing yourself
and that's
when I started reading Neruda.
>> Georgette Dorn: Was it really
wonderful to translate him?
Was it easy?
>> Forrest Gander: No,
it wasn't easy at all.
I mean, you know, living by the
sea, he makes up words, "el córelo,"
you know like "el mar
caracol [inaudible],"
the snail [inaudible] the sea,
some idiosyncratic vernacular
that was only used
for a short period.
In fact, I was going
to ask you, Marjorie,
if you knew what he was talking
about, or vivías en Argentina, no?
>> Marjorie Agosín: Si.
>> Forrest Gander:
¿Cerca del mar, o no?
>> Marjorie Agosín: No,
o sea es cerca del rio.
>> Forrest Gander: So Neruda has
the shortest poem in the book.
It's a [inaudible]
to his wife's ear.
It's starts out, you know, "oreja
maravillosa," marvelous ear,
double butterfly, let me praise, and
then the next line are [inaudible].
"Yo hablo de la pequeña oreja mas
amada, hecha tal vez de nácar,
amasada con arena de rosa, no.
Yo quiero celebrar una reja."
So for those who don't have Spanish,
so it's like, it starts out,
"My lover's ear, marvelous ear."
Then he says, "I'm not talking
about la pequeña," "the little ear,
most beloved, hecha tal vez de
nácar," kneaded perhaps with nicker
"con harina de rosa," with
rose flower; it's like what?
Where is he going?
He's like cooking his lover's ear.
Do you know the vernacular?
>> Marjorie Agosín: Arina de rosa.
>> Forrest Gander: For
"oreja del mar," yeah.
You do?
>> Unknown Speaker:
No, I'm just curious.
Isn't there in the [inaudible]
this thing, historically,
with eating people's flesh.
[ Inaudible ]
It's cannibalism.
>> Georgette Dorn:
I think it's a fish.
Yeah, I do know [inaudible]
in the Caribbean, [inaudible].
>> Forrest Gander: Well,
it turns out in the 50s,
but just for about 10 years.
None of my friends in Chile --
and Marjorie is from
my age don't know it.
Raúl Zurita didn't know it, but
people's grandmother's knew that
"oreja del mar" for a brief period
was what they called "abalone."
Abalone is little ear of the sea.
>> Georgette Dorn: Yeah, at one
point in my life, I heard that.
>> Forrest Gander: So I'm not
talking about the little ear
of the sea that you
cook, that are so tasty.
No, I'm talking about your ear.
>> Georgette Dorn:
[ Inaudible ]
Marjorie in terms of
Neruda, how is it possible
that these poems were
not found by anybody
or that he didn't want
to publish them?
How do you explain that?
>> Marjorie Agosín: Maybe
Forrest can answer better,
but he didn't want to publish.
I think a lot of people, you
know, because he's perfect
and he's imperfect and that's what
so beautiful about him, right?
Some people published too
much but I think it happened.
I don't know.
Some people may think that it
was destiny that they were found
so many years after Neruda's death
and his beloved, [inaudible],
Matilde, but I think it was like
a flaw; they were not found.
Matilde missed it but
I think that it's not
that he didn't want to publish.
What do you think?
>> Forrest Gander: No,
de acuerdo contigo.
Like Marjorie shows up in Isla Negra
and there's this guy
on a stone writing.
He was always writing and stuffing
the papers in different places
and so it was -- it's easy for some
of that work to have been hidden.
It's voluminous, so many,
so many boxes of his work,
so many things stuffed
into the backs of books.
His library was enormous.
>> Georgette Dorn: It's
very good that people spoke.
I mean he would talk to people.
He would sign anything, servilleta.
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah,
that's right, that's right.
He would sign napkins.
I mean he had a real
competition with Pablo DeRoca,
who considered himself
the people's poet.
>> Marjorie Agosín:
I think, for example,
I'm sorry the poem was too long
but it's always an epic long poem
and these poems are really --
so they are one of the
best of Neruda's work.
So they are part of this
tremendous "obra" literary work.
So it is strange and
perhaps so Nerudian
that nobody saw them really
except the eye of the [inaudible]
and who knows, you know --
Matilde was very careful
with her husband's work,
[inaudible] she admits this,
which his totally human
and this is maybe what
Neruda wanted to happen.
Thank you.
>> So when did find out that they
were available for translation?
What was the process?
I was just curious.
>> Forrest Gander: It
was a crazy process.
It was very under lock and key.
It was sort of very secretive.
Yeah. And so when the publishers
were bidding the English contract
and the publisher that put
the twice a day together,
the [inaudible] together, Cooper
Canyon, which has a long tradition
of promoting [inaudible] books sent
a number of translators this lock
and key manuscript and then
we submitted translations
and mine ended up being picked, but
the way the manuscript came to me,
I could open it and read it but
I couldn't select any part of it.
I couldn't alter any part of it.
I couldn't copy any part.
I couldn't send it to anyone.
I'd never seen such security.
Yeah. So I worked laboriously
on this but also
at an increasingly excited state.
>> Georgette Dorn:
It's a very good read.
Would it late in life you
think or was it early in life?
Do you any idea when
these were written?
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah, they
were written from about 1952 to,
we just heard one right
before he dies, 1973,
so about a 25-year period there.
It's midstride Neruda.
>> Georgette Dorn: That's wonderful.
[Inaudible] Nobel prize and
everybody knew in the 1971s.
So it's amazing how much
appeal to the common person.
I also think about when I walked
down the street here in Washington
and [inaudible] and if I ask anybody
in the street, nobody would know.
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah.
>> Georgette Dorn: But in Latin
America, if you walk the down
and someone won the Nobel Prize,
you were sure somebody would know.
It is an interesting observation.
>> Marjorie Agosín: I
also think towards later
in his life he made a conscious
decision and he wanted to write
in a way that people would find joy
in poetry and all the things he had.
I still think, for example,
[inaudible] have torras
to look a [inaudible], you know
the tomato that came from salad
or the artichoke or
the french fries.
You said that you didn't realize
that he was interested in food.
>> Georgette Dorn: Yes
and in animals too.
He would write on frogs
and all the animals, yeah.
>> Marjorie Agosín: And most
human beings are interested
in food and animals.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Georgette Dorn: So I
think we are going to open it
to the public with questions.
Will you identify yourself
when you ask a question
so I know who you are?
>> Marjorie Agosín:
We grew up together.
>> Thank you so much.
We appreciate the reading
with Marjorie.
We are family [inaudible] and I
[inaudible] about the translation
about the manuscript that you found
and so the evolution and some lines
that are erased, so [inaudible].
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah, so
that's part of why it's so useful
to have the holographic text because
in the poems that I'm looking
at there are lines crossed out,
which then I don't include I
think about honoring the poet.
If I have lines crossed out, I
don't want Rob publishing them,
but it's really interesting to
see it because it's the process
of his thinking through
and so you get to see
that with the holographic type.
Chile, so Roberto, the attaché
to the Industria Chile
is, of course, a writer.
That's who Chile sends
out to its ambassador.
It makes me proud.
I got to [inaudible].
So Neruda -- after Neruda,
it takes Nicanor Parra
to re-energize Chilean poetry and
maybe after Parra, Raúl Zurita,
who's still alive and has
Parkinson's and I was with Zurita
in Chile last year with my wife.
It was the last thing we did
together and walking up the street,
past a bunch of bars, and someone
at a bar recognized Zurita --
it gives you a sense of poetry's
place like Marjorie was saying
in Chile, stood up and began an
ovation, saying "Zurita, Zurita,"
and other people stood up and
also started clapping just
because this man was walking by.
And then Zurita who has
Parkinsons' froze because that's one
of the things that happens; you get
nervous, your body suddenly freezes
and he couldn't move, and the man
was shouting, "Go forward, Zurita.
Go forward.
You've led the way!"
>> Georgette Dorn: Adelante.
>> Forrest Gander: Zurita
was whispering, "I'm trying."
[ Laughter ]
>> Georgette Dorn: [Inaudible] was
here last here just about this time.
>> Forrest Gander: ¿No me diga?
>> Georgette Dorn: Oh,
yeah, just like this.
This was his the translator
with the Professor [inaudible].
>> Forrest Gander: [Inaudible] who
is a great translator who lives
in that city and just published an
edition of Zurita [inaudible] poems.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Any more questions?
Yes. Okay.
>> My name is Win Chi Chen,
I'm a [inaudible] poet.
So may I ask an outside question?
How do we translate
the sounds and rhymes
of the original Spanish
into English?
>> Forrest Gander: Okay and
Marjorie was also a translator
and a really good one.
>> Marjorie Agosín:
I'm so glad you think
so because I don't consider
myself as a translator.
>> Forrest Gander:
But you have, yeah.
>> Marjorie Agosín: Quickly, I just
want to say or mention, you know,
[inaudible] had to walk away from
Isla Negra because he didn't want
to be called the poet of Isla Negra
because he said there was
already a poet in Isla Negra,
so you can see the
strange [inaudible]
that happens in literature.
So he moved to a little nearby
town called " La cruces,"
but I would also like
to mention Enrique Lihn.
He was an extraordinary
Chilean poet,
a combination of [inaudible]
almost at the same time.
English, of course, even though
I was born in the United States,
I could be reported now
because I have an accent,
so English is not my native,
but I lived here long enough
to also embrace English and
love the English language
but I have translated from
the Spanish into the English.
I have translated from my
language to another language
and it's not exactly my
own, but I know it well.
So I think a poet like
Forrest, who writes in English,
has another sensibility
when he translates
Spanish-speaking poem [inaudible].
I think because you
master already the language
when you are translating a poem,
it's a different experience
than mine.
I think that I have borrowed
a little bit of the English
to convey the Spanish --
that English, I do not feel it
completely my own in a deep way
and perhaps the contribution to this
conversation in order to translate,
you have to be enamored of your own
native language and I am enamored
of Spanish, not English,
so I'm halfway translator.
>> Forrest Gander: The question that
you asked, for most of the poets
that I love, the sound and the
rhyme make meaning equally important
to the semantic meanings.
So sometimes I'll even risk going
away from a liberal translation
in order to capture a sound pattern
that I feel carries an emotional
weight that's more important
and that gets even harder
with Chinese and both the play
that you can have with
the way a character looks
and the way it can be
pronounced and the rhyme
of Chinese is the easiest
language in the world to rhyme in.
It's not even fun to
rhyme in Chinese.
It's too easy, but in Spanish, I'm
really listening for the sounds
and the rhythms and
trying to get those.
>> Georgette Dorn: How is that
some people translate informants?
American poets translates Spanish
but he does not know any Spanish.
I've known somebody like that.
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah, we've
all known somebody like that.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you know I think in the
old days, it was more justifiable
so that [inaudible]
Merwin, who is still alive.
>> Georgette Dorn: That's
the one I was thinking about.
He was one of our poet visitors.
>> Forrest Gander: Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, and he's a grand poet and he's
translated from a lot of languages
that he doesn't speak,
including Russian and a number
of Asian languages with
informants and those were important
because there has been
a lot of attention.
So that happened a lot in the 60s
when suddenly America was waking
up to the fact that there were
other languages in the world
and we might translate some, you
know, our literary production
of translated works is one
of the lowest percentage
wise in the world, 3%.
>> Georgette Dorn:
I didn't know that.
That's interesting.
>> Forrest Gander:
Yeah and [inaudible].
So his translations were really
important that they got done
and now there are more and more
poets who do speak other languages
who are capable of sort of,
you know, taking the lead.
>> Georgette Dorn: What do
you translate, Marjorie?
>> Marjorie Agosín: I have
translated for Gabriela Mistral,
which I think -- when Forrest
was talking about [inaudible],
she uses a lot of almost
19th century Spanish spoken
in rural communities in Chile,
especially Monte [inaudible],
Monte grande where she lived.
And I think I've never attempted
to translate [inaudible]
and I have also done some
translation of Nicanor Parra,
which is also [inaudible]
because to convey corrupt
and [inaudible] of [inaudible].
>> Forrest Gander: I was going
to ask you how did you get the
rights to translate Gabriela?
>> Marjorie Agosín:
I just [inaudible] they
never answered the letters.
You know, this is an
interesting story.
After [inaudible], I thought that
Gabriela could have been here,
all her work and her polished
work that did in Chile that I know
that all of you would agree that
that is where she should be,
but I think this is a
complex conversation,
but I think you'll understand
that it's really not a poems
that people read that much maybe
it was because of the complaints
to Chile, because she was a woman.
Neruda, somehow, [inaudible] he
was man and he would market himself
and men do that better than us.
So Gabriela was, unread,
almost invisible
and then she had this very long
and passionate relationship
with [inaudible], an
executor to her estate,
and when Gabriela Mistral died, her
poetry died with her and [inaudible]
because unfortunately
she [inaudible] most
of her unpublished work and
she never answered the ledgers.
So a very wonderful
publishers, small presses,
which are really the
backbone of American Poetry,
White [inaudible] press, let's
sent three to [inaudible]
and if she doesn't answer,
we acted in good faith
and we'll just go ahead and do it.
So people are not spies and they're
not that important and [inaudible]
on the poetry but somehow
we just published part
of the first translation
of this [inaudible] poetry
after this beautiful
translation done [inaudible] Huey
and now Gabriela is back in Chile.
She's [inaudible] and I hope
many, many people read her
and translate her because
she is [inaudible]
for multiple translations.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Gabriela recorded here
in the Library of Congress in 1952.
That's the only real recording
that she has made in her life.
>> Forrest Gander: Oh so
great, Library of Congress.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Georgette Dorn: This had to
be recorded many times because,
at one point, year of the woman
in 1975, so we made her record
into a [inaudible] and
"suspiros," and she would say, "Oh,
I'm so tired, can we take a break?"
[ Inaudible ]
I think there are still more
things that needs to be --
you know she was a
tremendous correspondent
in spite of [inaudible].
What do you think, Roberto?
There is a need for more of
Gabriela to be translated?
>> Robert Casper: Si,
more to translate.
>> I thought it was interesting
the underlying intent,
I'm sorry the comment
that [inaudible] had.
I just thought that
this was interesting.
I haven't read much of Neruda
but I thought it was interesting
and I did see the film yesterday,
which was good, but the comments
that were made about the 3% are
translated, poet of the people.
It seems to me different art
form or different cultures, etc.,
in this country, there
doesn't seem to be as much
of a resonance towards culture but
in Britain, they have more written,
you have Shakespeare and you
don't have as many opera stars
or operas created and
I wondered what is it
that makes a culture
create a poet of the people
because it's not just Latin in South
America, the Ireland has its call
and Irish side resinates
with me, but in America,
it does seem that there's
not as faithful at looking
at the present administration,
there has been lots
of call [inaudible] Tiffany to come
out of it, but it's been translated
into humor that's very [inaudible]
and visceral, and invisible and not
into [inaudible] a lot of the
nuance that Neruda during his time.
Is that a time thing?
Is that a culture thing?
Is it all of the above?
What other elements do
you see created in Neruda
or the absence of a Neruda?
>> Marjorie Agosín: This is a
question for seminar discussion.
So what you say Ireland,
[inaudible], Russia, Chile,
so many countries that have
famous poets and how do you refer
to the United States, which also has
an extraordinary literary tradition
that is intertwined, [inaudible],
the Children's English Literature
and you're saying why their poetry
doesn't have the same resonance?
This is very personal response.
I'd like to use just
one word, "greed."
Poetry doesn't make money and this
is a highly capitalistic society,
always a penny.
So the vocation of poetry
doesn't sell, really.
I think it's very sad to
speak this way but if you look
at how much money we pay
as taxpayers for the war
and how little we pay for the
National Endowment for the Arts,
it may explain and how I think a
lot of poets, including myself,
have to earn a living
as a college professor
because no one can
survive as a poet.
So I think they can at least
maintain this excentric poets
and do poetry reading
for academic elite
but somehow I do not see
poetry in the streets,
a poetry that people seen
it and people remember it.
This is a highly isolation
vocation, individualistic
and it has a very beautiful
side and an extremely dark one
and the dark one perhaps is the fact
that words don't matter that much,
that maybe [inaudible] matters
more, maybe stores matters more
and other countries value
words in a different way.
Countries like Finland or Israel,
which are relatively country,
have one of the largest
publishing industries
and especially the countries that
have more words in translation.
So I don't know.
I think we all know [inaudible],
our politics, our history.
In the 60s, there was
poetry and more songs.
Who knows maybe now there will
be more poetry and more songs
because I think it humanizes
people more the Arts.
I think that poetry -- we are
interested in what is more suitable
and I think we have to
change and look for the food
that will sustain your soul and
believe me, poetry is also food.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Am I right?
>> Forrest Gander: I agree
with absolutely everything
that Marjorie said.
Another trajectory to answering
your question is, dude,
you're not hanging out
with the right people.
I mean, one, we had Whitman --
Whitman and Dickenson who are sure
the diastolic and systolic pulse
of American Literature and who
have international literature
in every other country and then
that poetry is really alive
in every city in the country.
Every night, there
are poetry reading,
one for Juan Herrera is a
hugely popular poet and hundreds
of people come to his reading.
Robert [inaudible] who is just died,
people couldn't get
into readings of him.
There would 800 people and people
standing in another room to try
to hear, and [inaudible]
Rich also a really popular,
really influential poet.
I think we have them, but
we get distracted especially
in the United States.
It's an epic of the spectacle and in
a way, poetry is the anti-spectacle.
It's this thing that can happen all
alone with you in a room with a page
in front of you and like Marjorie
said, your soul can open up.
Like "¡Que Milagro!"
What an amazing in
this age of spectacle
that that private intimate activity
can still be so powerful and it is.
>> Georgette Dorn: They have poetry
prizes in -- [inaudible] sector,
they began in the 30s here.
Am I right about that in the 1930s?
And so I think there's been some
interest Washington at least.
My hometown in Modesto,
has a little poetry center.
>> Forrest Gander:
That's a famous one.
>> Georgette Dorn: Little house.
>> Forrest Gander: The
writing center, yeah.
>> I think we are finished.
We are going to thank
our poets and Georgette
for these wonderful conversations.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.